I've been working from home over the
last couple of days because everybody
who can work from home should work from
home
I've also some mild symptoms of
coronavirus and upon medical advice I
was tested and that test has been
positive so I'll be self isolating here
until next Thursday
currently for me the symptoms so far
have been very mild so I've been able to
carry on with the work driving forward
the UK response and also being able to
just say a massive thank you to
everybody in the NHS working social care
and right across the board on the
response
I thought the clap for the carers moment
that was unbelievable and so wonderful
to see the whole country you know in
support for those who look after us and
I'll be continuing to do everything I
can to get our carers the support that
feed and I'll be doing that from here
but with less gusto and then for next
Thursday once I'm out of time so
isolation and I hope with no more
symptoms then I'll be able to get back
stuck in and into the office where
necessary but the truth is that all of
us can learn that working from home home
can be really really effective